curry ties the game  [Applause]  37 points for steph curry  they get at the call while pope almost  lost it shot clock at seven  james two defenders on him to caldwell  pope inside he's tied up by green  throws it back up top james puts up the  three oh it's  gone lebron james from downtown  as the shot clock expires  is on curry base more to inbound  pool coming free curry trying to get  free lost the ball that's  it the lakers are in the playoffs  the warriors need to play on friday what  a thriller here at the staples center  [Applause]  phoenix on sunday the warriors will play  the grizzlies on friday night  to keep their season alive and the  respect from the two former mvps